CANNOT REMAIN IN POWER.
FOR ALL OF OUR SAKES.
TULSA GABBERT IS A FORMER MEMBER
OF CONGRESS.
FOLLOWING THIS TOPIC VERY
CLOSELY, TAKING A LOT OF HEAT
FOR IT FOR TELLING THE TRUTH
REGARDLESS BEAR THANKS SO MUCH
FOR COMING ON TONIGHT.
IT IS NOT EVEN A PERSONAL ATTACK
AND I'D CERTAINLY DON'T MEAN TO
BE DISRESPECTFUL FOR ANYBODY IN
HIS CONDITION, BUT THE
UNITED STATES, THE FUTURE OF THE
COUNTRY HANGS IN THE BALANCE AND
I DON'T UNDERSTAND HOW THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY CAN CONTINUE
THIS SUPPORT SOMEONE WHO'S
COMPLETELY OUT OF CONTROL.
>> I THINK WHAT WE ARE SEEING
HERE, TUCKER, FOCUSING ON HIS
COMMENTS ABOUT REGIME CHANGE.
SAID OUT LOUD WHAT THE AIMS AND
OBJECTIVES OF HIS
ADMINISTRATION'S POLICIES ARE,
WHICH IS REGIME CHANGE IN
RUSSIA, TO GET BIDEN OUT OF
POWER.
THEY ARE DOING SO THROUGH USING
THE PRIMARY WEAPONS OF ECONOMIC
WARFARE.
THEY ARE DOING SO BY WAGING THIS
MODERN DAY SIEGE AGAINST RUSSIA,
ISOLATING, CANE TAINTING,
DESTROYING THE ECONOMY, STARVING
THE RUSSIAN PEOPLE AND HOPE THAT
THE RUSSIAN PEOPLE OR THE
MILITARY WILL RISE UP AND REVOLT
AND OVERTHROW THEIR GOVERNMENT,
AND GET RID OF PUTIN.
THE REASON THEY ARE LYING ABOUT
THIS TO THE AMERICAN PEOPLE,
TUCKER, THEY KNOW WE ARE SICK
AND TIRED OF OUR COUNTRY WAGING
REGIME CHANGE, WE REMEMBER HOW
COSTLY AND DEVASTATING THESE
WARS IN IRAQ, LIBYA, SYRIA HAVE
BEEN.
WE REJECTED THEM WHOLEHEARTEDLY.
WORTHY TO COME OUT AND TELL THE
TRUTH, THEIR POLLS WOULD TANK
EVEN MORE THAN THEY ALREADY ARE
AND THEIR POLITICS WOULD SUFFER.
>> LET ME ASK YOU...
I BELIEVE YOU COMPLETELY.
CLEARLY THEY WANT THAT.
BUT WHAT COMES AFTER?
KILLING PEOPLE IS RELATIVELY
EASY.
BUILDING THINGS IS REALLY HARD.
THIS IS A REAL COUNTRY, A HUGE
ENERGY RESERVE, BIDEN GOES THEN
WHAT?
HAVE THEY THOUGHT THAT THROUGH?
>> THE ANSWER TO THAT IS CLEARLY
NO.
THIS ISN'T JUST MY OPINION.
WE HAVE HISTORY TO LOOK FORWARD
TO TODAY ANSWER THIS QUESTION
AND EVERY ONE OF THESE REGIME
CHANGE WARS WE'VE SEEN HAVE THE
ANSWER TO THE QUESTION "WHAT
HAPPENS NEXT."
WHO TAKES CHARGE AFTER YOU
TOPPLE THAT DICTATOR.
WHAT WEAPONS WILL THEY HAVE
UNDER THEIR CONTROL?
THEY NEVER HAVE AN ANSWER TO
THAT QUESTION WHAT WE ARE SEEING
PLAY OUT BEFORE US IS FOLLOWING
THAT EXACT SAME TRACK RECORD BUT
MORE DANGEROUSLY SO BECAUSE THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE ARE SMART ENOUGH
TO KNOW THAT A REGIME CHANGE WAR
AGAINST A NUCLEAR ARMED RUSSIA
IS VERY DIFFERENT FROM ANY OTHER
THAT'S BEEN WAGED BEFORE AND
WILL RESULT IN DISASTROUS
CONSEQUENCES THAT GO BEYOND
ANYTHING WE COULD EVEN IMAGINE.
>> Tucker: THESE PEOPLE
COULDN'T KEEP TRACK OF THEIR OWN
DANGEROUS BIOLOGICAL AGENCY WE
WERE FUNDING IN UKRAINE.
NO IDEA WHERE THEY ARE,
OBVIOUSLY.
THEY'LL KEEP TRACK OF 6,000
WEAPONS QUESTION MIKE I DON'T
THINK SO.
YOU ARE SAYING THINGS THAT
NOBODY IN THE PUBLIC SPHERE IS
SAYING.
YOU'VE SAID RECENTLY THAT
FACEBOOK, MARK ZUCKERBERG, HAS
BEEN SUPPRESSING YOUR MESSAGE.
HERE'S A CLIP OF YOU EXPLAINING
IT.
>> WHEN PEOPLE TRY TO TYPE MY
NAME IN INSTAGRAM, MY ACCOUNT
DOES NOT SHOW UP.
ALSO GETTING A LOT OF REPORTS
FROM PEOPLE WHO ARE TRYING TO @
ME AND THEY ARE GETTING A
WARNING THAT THIS ACCOUNT HAS
POSTED DISINFORMATION.
>> Tucker: THAT'S THE
CONCLUSION I'M COMING TO?
>> PRETTY MUCH.
THAT'S THE CONCLUSION.
BIG TECH IS ACTING AS THIS
DICTATORSHIP TELLING US WHAT WE
ARE ALLOWED TO SAY AND NOT
ALLOWED TO SAY.
THE THING THAT THEY ARE SAYING
SPREADING DISINFORMATION, THERE
IS NO EVIDENCE, NO EXAMPLES, NO
NOTICE SAYING, HEY, THIS IS WHAT
YOU'RE SAYING THAT IS FALSE.
ABSOLUTELY NONE OF THAT.
COMES DOWN TO IF YOU ARE SHINING
A LIGHT ON THE TRUTH AND YOU
WILL BE SHUT DOWN AND SILENCED